these are three things you might not
know about Joe Rogan starting off with
his first ever sponsorship deal from
Fleshlight who saw so much early
potential in Joe's podcast they were
eager to stuff his pockets with fat
loads of cash but fact number two is
even more surprising because although
Joe Rogan is known nowadays for his
shiny bald head he actually used to have
hair plugs in fact Joe is reflected on
the times he got plugged up on multiple
occasions and always states he regrets
not having a shaved head sooner living
with regret seems to be out of character
for Joe which is why it's been years now
since he's kicked the habits of one of
his biggest sources of Shame video games
Joe Rogan used to be addicted to a
first-person shooter game called quake
and did everything from competing in
professional tournaments to building an
extensive gaming setup in his old Studio